and 8 news now continues to stay on top
of homelessness across the valley in
particular near the flamingo Arroyo
Trail and it looks like the county has
added a new feature to prevent homeless
encampments from being set up along that
trail but not everybody's on board eight
news now reporter Madison Kimbrough has
the details
the flamingo Arroyo Trail is over six
miles long and here at this portion on
Desert Inn you can see the county has
added two gates closing it off at night
now they you know posted a date up there
it's inconvenient I gotta find a park a
public park or something like that where
I can go you know take my dog or you
know take myself
Ayanna who's lived at Cottonwood Creek
Apartments for several years happy that
the flamingo Arroyo Trail is clear but
not too pleased that now there will be a
curfew for residents like her to use it
it's really inconvenient because I pay
rent over here you know and I should be
able to uh use the different properties
and things like that that have available
County Commissioner tick Seger Bloom
installing these Gates that will be
locked From Dusk Till Dawn I've asked my
staff to look at into putting Gates on
both ends of the bridge so that at least
during the night time when the police
aren't out there that no one could get
into the bridge and and Camp over the
past few months 8 news now has followed
commissioner Sager Bloom as he's teamed
up with Metro Public Works code
enforcement and Park police to clear
portions of the trail
after residents from all across the
valley voiced concerns about the
homeless taking over their neighborhoods
honestly it's been very frustrating down
in Dallas and Sahara it's it's a
disaster so it's it's really kind of
whack them all but that's why we need a
I need more Park police frankly so
that's one of the things that's going to
be the upcoming budget is more Park
police as for this portion of the trail
near Pecos McLeod and Desert Inn other
residents believe adding the gates was a
good move I'm happy to see that they're
locking the bridge at night when you
have people who have basically no place
else to go and then they start to take
up you know residency on the bridges it
wasn't walkable anyway currently there
aren't any plans to add Gates like these
to other portions of the trail as the
county wants to see how this one does
first reporting near Desert Inn Pecos
McLeod Madison Kimbrough 8 news now
Madison thank you County officials say
they're ready to unveil what they're
calling their navigation Center on
Boulder Highway next month Sager Bloom
describes it as an intake Center healing
rather helping those suffering from
homelessness and intermediate and
long-term housing